the witness for the prosecution
testified to the life
lost when george floyd drew his last
breath
beneath a police officer's knee
people would attend church just because
he was deaf
nobody would go out there until they
seen him
and he just was like a person that
everybody loved around the community he
he just
knew how to make people feel better
a unique spark of life doctrine in
minnesota allows prosecutors to humanize
crime victims like george floyd as his
brother philanese did as the prosecution
showed pictures of his slain brother
prosecutors began day 11 in the murder
trial of former police officer derek
chauvin
with a cardiologist who laid the blame
for george floyd's death
directly on chauvin saying his knee
starved floyd of oxygen
and stopped his heart in this case mr
george
george floyd died from a cardiopulmonary
arrest
it was caused by low oxygen levels
and those low oxygen levels were induced
by the prone restraint and positional
asphyxiation that he was subjected to
dr jonathan rich ruled out the defense's
alternative theory
an overdose of the fentanyl and
methamphetamine an autopsy found in
floyd's system
if not for the officers holding him down
he said floyd
would have survived the encounter after
the shooting of another unarmed black
man just 16 kilometers from the site of
the trial in brooklyn center minnesota
shovin's lawyer asked the judge to
sequester or
isolate the jury the fear is that they'd
be unduly prejudiced or might be
inclined to convict chauvin to avoid
more civil unrest
but the judge said no i'm going to deny
the motion to sequester the jury and for
additional vladir
this is a totally different case after
two weeks of prosecution witnesses the
defense begins to present its case on
tuesday and it's likely to be a short
one
the judge says he expects it to be over
in time for closing arguments on monday
and when that happens he says the jury
will be sequestered until they render a
verdict
as they deliberate prosecutors hope
they'll reflect on the man
chauvin is accused of killing he showed
us
like how to treat our mom
and how to respect our mom he he just
he loved her so dearly
when we went to the funeral it's just
george just sat there at the casket over
and over again
he would just say mama mama
over and over again
it's not likely to be lost on the jury
that those are also among floyd's last
words as he lay on the pavement
evidence the prosecution is likely to
suggest in its closing arguments
that george floyd wasn't suffering from
a heart attack or a drug overdose
but knew that he was taking his last
breaths as his life was being choked out
of him
john hendren al jazeera minneapolis